texas jury finds alex jones must pay
more than 4.1 million dollars to sandy
hook victim's parents for calling the
massacre a giant hoax this story is
absolutely insane
first they say this is far lower than
the figure parents had asked them to
award 150 million dollars in damages
which their lawyer found a fitting
penalty for jones's decade of deceit
december will mark the 10th anniversary
of the massacre the jury which reached
the verdict on the first day of
deliberations has yet to award punitive
damages and will return on friday to
consider that unresolved matter only the
size of the award has been an issue at
trial as the judge issued a rare default
judgment against jones before trial for
failing to comply with his discovery
obligations
that's not that's weird right you're a
lawyer yeah it is it's not something you
see
a lot in litigation typically if there
are disputes between parties on
discovery so for example if
a plaintiff or a defendant
is seeking documents or answers to
interrogatories or other questions and
discovery there's a process that you go
through right the
council for both parties confer with one
another they try to understand what the
disputes are
and
ultimately
the parties go to the court and ask the
judge to weigh in on
whether or not to order the party to
produce those documents
and i'm not familiar with the specific
details of alex's case and the
procedural history of
how the default judgment happened but it
is a rare thing for a court
to
not
provide any sort of intermediary
sanction
right they just went straight to
default less than default which would be
uh negative inferences perhaps from an
evidentiary standpoint or other uh
sanctions that the court might levy but
not uh going straight to a finding of
liability do you think
do you think alex jones can can
appeal this and and potentially
win
potentially there's a ground for appeal
for sure if
again and not knowing what the texas
state court precedents are
uh
right now but
they're in theory yes would be a
a basis to appeal
the finding of of liability which
is the threshold finding for
uh the damages that flowed out today in
the 4 million or so verdict so this is
the story from npr conspiracy theorist
alex jones ruled liable in sandy hook
defamation case this is from november 15
2021 they said a monday ruling from a
connecticut court which found jones and
other defendants liable for defamation
brought swift reaction from an attorney
or any of the families
superior court judge barbara bella cited
the defendant's willful non-compliance
the discovery process as the reasoning
behind the ruling bellas noted that
defendants failed to turn over financial
and analytics data that were requested
multiple times by the sandy hook family
plaintiffs now this is a connecticut
court
the the the story about the four million
dollars as a texas court i know that
he's got other defamation cases coming
from these parents but um the reason i
bring up that story i believe it's it's
the same one but um
i'm not entirely sure what i know is
that um or what i can say
alex told me they complied with
everything but no matter what they gave
they were told they weren't complying
i'm not saying you need to believe alex
jones i'm just saying that's what he's
asserting now the question i have is
if a court orders you to hand something
over that you don't have
and then issues a ruling in default like
what do you do
assume let's let's operate from the
assumption that alex jones did comply
with discovery as he claims
and they rule in default anyway what do
you do
oh you go to the court and you explain
all the things that you did to
to to produce documents oh yeah you you
try to uh create uh
you you show the court
for example if you're searching for
documents across a corporation for
example what search terms you used how
you
searched for documents how you collected
them and ultimately produced them
you know you you offer the opportunity
for somebody to come and do a forensic
analysis
uh to to make sure you're not hiding
something right those those are the
steps that you could go through to
sort of prove your your uh that you've
you've complied with your obligations
but that doesn't sound like that
opportunity was provided in this
particular case yeah which again is
going to potentially raise
uh
appealable issues so i wonder if this is
just political
you know four million dollars i'm just
gonna come out and say it for alex jones
he said in trial something like anything
more than two million would like damage
the company or something
i don't believe it
i think i think a four million dollar
ruling alex probably left got in his car
and then went yes
because like a lot of people are posting
on twitter that this may this may as
well have been a victory for for alex
four million dollars because he he he
makes so much money
now he doesn't make as much money as he
used to which is another big element of
this of this trial of this case is that
they're trying to claim
people are just it's so frustrating
dealing with you know
people are saying in the trial they said
alex jones made 165 million dollars in
sales wow alex jones made 165 million no
that's that's that's gross what's the
net what's the what's the profit what's
the take home what after taxes like how
much money does men actually have
a lot that's why i'm saying like yeah
four million sucks but for someone as
well off as alex as big as his empire is
he could probably pay that how long do
they take to pay that do they give him
like a year every night does he have to
make payments is it a dude
people don't know anything about this
stuff he's probably never going to pay
him
like there was a there was a viral post
or there's a post on reddit and then
they were like i think it was related to
o.j simpson they said you know it was a
30 million dollar wrongful death lawsuit
he's only paid like a hundred grand
after like 30 years why
because you can't squeeze blood out of a
turnip oh like
what are you gonna do yeah and people
arrange their assets in ways that can
be advantageous in that regard i think
the enron executives right and when in
in uh in the 2000s who had multi-million
dollar verdicts that were levity against
them who bought large houses in
in florida if i'm not uh mistaken or if
i'm remembering correctly because
essentially they could put uh put their
assets into a home that couldn't be
levied against
uh to collect against the judgment yeah
they can't take your house from you can
they or it depends on what state you're
in in terms of how
uh how far a judgment creditor can go to
collect against you like i said i think
in the case of the enron executives
there are special rules in florida that
that that allow people to put their
assets weren't they like homes weren't
they like buying like a 100 million
dollar house and then being like sorry
i'm in bankruptcy
i i i don't know remember if it was it
was it was that much but it was big
houses big big houses and lots of money
and then when they start like a bunch of
like home renovations they just start
the renovations and they're like sorry
all the money's out even though it
hasn't been built yet yeah
i don't know it's easier than that i
mean here's here's one thing you could
do right let's say you uh want to engage
in corrupt behavior or let's say you
have plans to be corrupt and you know
that you can't take the money from an
organization say like i don't know um
you're an elected official
and you want people to pay you for
favors so
um you'll create something called like a
global foundation
and then as let's just say your
secretary of state or something like
that under obama under obama yeah and
then and then all of a sudden hundreds
of millions of dollars are pouring into
your foundation which is unrelated to
you right you know that's one way or or
let's say um
you uh want to do large private equity
deals with china but you are an elected
official so you have your son
fly on the government plane with you
just hypothetically of course and then
um share bank accounts with them even
though i have no idea how how that works
legally but share phone numbers that way
if you were the one communicating you
can always just say it was your kid and
that way
you know you can try and cover up those
are things that somebody might do
actually just for the sake of clarity
i'm literally referencing
what joe biden and hillary clinton have
been accused of doing in no way trying
to encourage people to engage in any of
those behaviors right the clinton
foundation right took a lot of money and
then when she was when she lost all of a
sudden the clinton foundation stopped
getting like money just dried up and
just and then they disbanded it and now
it's back is that yeah they were like
hey we're gonna win again or something
like that when you said that they one
thing alex or someone that feels like
they've been wronged by the process can
go to the court and see if they can
rectify like discovery or whatever is
the court just basically the judge in
this case it is the judge right right so
you if you have a discovery dispute
you try to work it out with the other
party first you do something called beat
and confer with the other side to see if
you can
resolve the dispute without having to
get the judge involved but ultimately if
you're unsatisfied with what the other
side is doing in terms of the documents
that they've given or the answers
they've given discovery
you go to the court and you move to
compel and you ask the judge to order
them to
order them to uh
to uh provide
responsive documents or answers
but what if you don't have it like
what are you supposed to do
there's nothing yeah nothing you can do
there is nothing you can do other than
other than again what i said earlier
which is show
the court the efforts that you've
undertaken to
the judge
the curtain the judge can just be like
you're lying
potentially yeah
yeah i think people need to realize
everybody thinks you live in this world
of laws and that the laws dictate what
will happen they don't they're more like
guidelines i think it's funny when
people say you know because carrie lake
is big in the news and they're talking
about her election there was a funny
article that said if carrie alike gets
her legally impossible wish donald trump
will be ineligible to run for president
because you can only win twice or
whatever and i was like legally
impossible i like how they say that as
if like the declaration of independence
was legal as it pertained to the british
parliament like no a bunch of guys drank
and then said you know what we're
declaring independence
and the crown was like you can't that's
not legal and they're like we don't care
so at a certain point humans just make
decisions to do things and so we might
sit back and be like you can't do that
the court says this and it's like bro
the judge's gonna do whatever they want
and good luck
if you get a bad judge what are you
gonna do about it well that's why you
have an appeals process i know it's cool
but what have you got a bad supreme
court yeah well right you may reject it
it's just
no that's that that's true i mean it we
we live in a fallen world and in a legal
system that has
limitations on its ability to do justice
yeah that's right but but i i will say
just in defense of the legal system in
some ways we are blessed and fortunate
in the united states
there
where we do i i believe in most cases
civil cases that i've been involved in
certainly judges that are trying to do
their best to reach reach the right
result
so we do have we do have that blessing
here in the united states that a lot of
other countries don't have no i mean we
got a pretty good system i think the
issue is just we're getting to this
point culturally where you have two
distinct americas you have the
multicultural democracy you have the
constitutional republic you have you now
have judges it you know i understand
sometimes you'll get a judge and i've
watched law order right right they'll be
like this is good news you know we've
got judge smith who's you know not a fan
of x or y which means we'll probably be
able to get you know these things filed
or something like that they'll say stuff
like that right and i've been involved
in legal issues in the real world where
i've been advised if you file in this
jurisdiction you're gonna have this
judge and he really hates this stuff
and so it's like okay you take those
things into consideration
that's to a degree understandable the
perceptions of the judges and how they
interpret the law but we're getting to
the point where these judges are like i
hate alex jones he's an evil man cnn
told me so i'm not going to let him win
no matter what he does it is we're
getting we're getting to that point i'm
not saying this of the current judge
some people are accusing i'm saying
quite literally
like i'm saying it's hypothetical we're
getting the point where your judge is
going to be like i don't i don't know or
care who you are you're maga
and that's obviously
not a place where we need to be and
that's a disturbing place
it's a scary place that's where we're at
if anything alex jones was the one who
got defamed because after
his sandy hook comments they twisted
that into saying that he also claimed
parkland didn't happen and all sorts of
things didn't happen none of that was
true they brought up how like some of
the stuff he was saying was him reading
comments from users
and news articles
and so it's like
there should also be room for alex jones
to be a performer because that's partly
what he is
i i don't like i don't like the idea
that um look the sandy hook families
these are private individuals you don't
you don't get on a big platform and
start accusing private individuals of
stuff you shouldn't do it for anybody
right i didn't watch that
what he said at the time yeah i mean he
had he had his own employ his own
employees were telling him to stop what
did he say exactly is it public uh is it
on youtube i don't think that you're
allowed to re-post what he said on
youtube it's it's it's not and i would
not be able to quote exactly what he
said but i know there were various
instances of him accusing them of being
christ's actors or saying they weren't
real but a lot of it was him
being like oh look what this person said
and look what this person said
and then they've also they also accused
him of saying things like if you really
did lose your children i'm so sorry and
they're like what does that mean and
they were saying those statements as
well were part of the defamation what
you got to understand about private
individuals
you can't like the standard is really
low for for defamation against a private
individual
or i shouldn't say it's really low it's
just really high if you're a public
figure
so what they tried doing with the
covington catholic kids was claiming
they were involuntary public figures
like that's absurd
but alex didn't get a jury trial in this
as to whether he defamed him so we
didn't even go over that stuff
jones was instructed that he was not
allowed to say that he was that he
didn't do it he was not allowed to
defend himself at all they said
he he wasn't allowed to say comply with
discovery and he wasn't allowed to say
he he didn't defame them and he wasn't
allowed to say that he didn't mean to
call them and cause them intentional
harm
why couldn't that's crazy
and on the first issue about not being
able to say he wasn't liable
that was already the
decision it was a truck it was a it was
a trial on damages so that's not
out of the ordinary um at all right
because if you're only there to try
damages you
the issue of liability is already it is
out of the ordinary right it was rare
that there's a default right correct
correct right right so the fact that he
never got an opportunity to be like
here's what happened correct that being
said i gotta tell you guys
um before the trial even happened i know
people who people have told me it's here
say but they were like i heard so and so
said to jones you have to stop doing
this
and then in the trial they actually
brought up communications where
employees at infowars were telling him
like why are you doing this it's not
worth it you need to stop
and he didn't and you know people have
brought up that he was drinking
probably got arrogant i mean this dude
was making a lot of money he was making
what like here's the crazy thing they
said it was like 16 i'm sorry 165
million in sales
165 million dollars in sales
i also i also heard scuttlebutt was like
he was making like 10 million a month
so if you're doing
165 million per year so you're so if
it's if you're making 10 million imagine
what his profit margins are some
speculate it was around 70 percent
makes sense it's a lot of money it's a
lot of money and and i'll tell you this
too like the 4.1 million i know it's bad
there's precedent like they're trying to
get a political victory or whatever it
is people think the the thing about this
4.1 million is
i'm willing to bet jones got
crypto or something
you know he knew this was coming so you
have to imagine that if you know it's
coming and you're wanting to work in a
company you're going to start you're
going to ramp up everyone's salaries
your kids are going to get their
inheritance very quickly and then
they're going to come through and be
like it's all gone you're ordering your
fare you are ordering your affairs
strategically yep at that point though
there are
uh remedies potentially that these
plaintiffs can take to try to trace that
money to some extent but yeah well let
me ask you then as a lawyer like if uh
if alex jones paid a million dollars to
an employee could they then get that
money back
well the problem is what what did the
what did the employee do right after
they after they got it right let's say
let's say let's let's say that someone
was contracted to uh
produce a documentary
and
uh they're a documentary filmmaker and
alex said we'll give you uh a million
dollars to produce this this massive
documentary and they said you got it
it's a third part let's say it's a
third-party company that's contract with
alex jones
could you how would you get the money
from them i mean they're not involved in
your lawsuit you can't just take the
money from them they're doing work right
yeah i mean provide provided it's a
legitimate arms length transaction
that's not right that's fraudulent how
would you no yeah sure it's like an
invoice came in and it said here's the
proposed budget for the film right and
they said we're going to pay you the
million dollars
what do you do and and and that gets
into the interplay of you know potential
bankruptcy questions which i'm not a you
know i'm not an expert in in bankruptcy
um but uh fraudulent transfers and
things of that nature where creditors
will go and try to but i'm saying not
not fraudulent like right let's say alex
jones has never done a million dollar
documentary before right gets sued
and then he decides to do one
now he's broke because he spent all the
companies money you assume he says i
don't know any money they say where is
it we spent it i'm running the company
right and and then you show like a
legitimate invoice and transaction and
budgeting plan for this big project
right and then that's what you think is
happening with the upcoming documentary
what he's doing that that is not his
actual documentary alex's war is not
related to infowars i'm not i'm not i'm
i'm not referring to anything about alex
jones i'm saying like in the event that
you get sued couldn't you just spend the
money
well and whoever's hands it belongs to
you
that's their private business right and
then like you couldn't take i couldn't
take your money
you know if i was suing ian and
right now
and and again i think what would happen
is
you you would have to apply the you
would have to apply the law uh in the
case law in the jurisdiction where
you're in in his case in texas
as they're going to go and try to
collect against him personally they're
going to try to collect against these
corporations then you're going to have a
overlay with the bankruptcy court and
how
uh the bankruptcy process plays out and
which uh who's gonna get paid and what
priority because i imagine he has other
creditors not just these judgment
creditors that are out there that uh
that uh he owes money to right so yeah i
don't i don't i don't it's a four
million dollar judgment and i'd be
surprised if they actually even get any
money i mean they might get a little bit
what are they what's going to happen i
mean
right right because they it sounds like
they might have to get in line right
with a lot of other people yep in the
bankruptcy branch and then there's
questions of like
let's say alex jones just says
i declare bankruptcy i liquidate the
assets i pay everybody off and then he
takes a lucrative contract working for a
different company and so sure out of his
the money they're paying him maybe they
only pay him a small you know six figure
salary so he only has to pay a certain
percentage but then he gets to live
luxuriously you know through other
people like he's alex jones he could
take a cell phone with 20 bucks and film
a video and get a million views thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you